Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to "WELCOME TO THE GAME"
Now I didn't do so good last time because I didn't know
exactly what I was supposed to do,
but I have to start a new game because I died,
and then I was the victim in the red room and now I'm dead!
So I need to start over, and this time I'm going to make a very meticulous list
of the websites that I've been 'do' so that I know-
SHUT UP ADAM! I know what I'm doin'
So that I know EXACTLY where to go
I'm goin' to have my notepad up, ready to go,
and these are a liiittle bit different
than they were before so I gotta go through this
All
*dramatic pause*
...carefully-like
It's a little early...
But let's go check out the bathroom cams because those are-
DAMMIT! GOD DAMMIT! I JUST GOT STARTED!
Alright fine you can bring on your hacks I know what I'm doing
DOS blocker huh?
The eaaaaasy crap
Speed it up! I'mmm a champion!
Okay, so now we're gonna go through this
I don't think I'm gonna be
thwarted
this early on, I don't think I'm gonna- *burp*
be doing anything that,
I've got going on so
I just need to go through it and I need to
find websites that I can actually go to,
pour through them, get every single little detail I can
It's this one again
See why that? Why that one over there?
W-why that one!? There's nothing here, it's the same thing an-
I believe this might a red herring
so I'm pretty sure that's a red herring but that was the same one in the other one too...
"Chosen Awake"
*claptrap nuts*
AGAIN.
GOOOD DAMMIT.
*mimicks the skull* Ha ha ha-haaa
Get some extra laughs in there
Alright we gotta type up a storm
Good thing I know what I'm doing
*counter beeps*
Hashtag define pcaps slinger underscore- whoop
Underscore h
hashtag- whoop
*mumbles* hashtag define
IP underscore Half Life 2
ip
Zero- oop. Zero x Zero f
BAM GOT IT
dING DONG BING BONG
okay
I'm not dead yet
"FAMILY DRUG SHOP"
Good ol' friendly fami- OOH Heroin :D
Oh, all of your family needs!
Products, we need to go through the whole website. *Mark pretends like he's never been here before*
If there's nothing here, then there's nothing here, but I need to find out exactly how much is here.
WHY!
There's a lot of hacks!
Oh... wha--? WHAT?!
WHAT?! WAIT WHAT DO YOU MEAN "Fail"?
What did I do? I didn't get the chance to do anything!
HUH?!!!
DAYS LOST: FOUR?!
FOUR?! :0
What do you mean four days lost? What, did they put me in a time prison?
The fuck was that all about?
Okay, so...
...I guess I'm okay so I have to find out what kind of heroin I can get.
At this point, I'd welcome an ab-duct-tor... cause I'm not ready.
AHH!
Eat a diiiiick.
There we go, okay,  now I got it.
Cause apparently you only get one chance on that, that's super weird-
OH!
Code- Code!- CODE!
BANG! Code, got it! Okay.
Even though I lost... the day.
That doesn't matter, I got it done!
Family drug shop: DONE!  Father Donald had something,
but Father Donald was only available at like: 3:00 AM last time.
So okay, Hot Burners is done. I can remember- nah.
Hot Burners has nothing. Okay?, That's fine.That's good. Okay, we're good.
Illuminati: The Website! Nope!
Doesn't work.
*Heartbeat-like noise*
I'm gonna test out...
Cause I think...
There's random noises that aren't actually anything.
I don't know that though.
OH, OH, OOH, OOH, OHH! Tango down. Yes!
Okay got something!
*Mumbling* 4-c... 3cfe
Okay, Got it. That's gooood
That's gooooooood.
Alright, we got something. We got another one.
Oh that's good. Tango down, we got it.
(groaning) Ugggggh
Why you do this to meeeeeeeeee!
TOO MANY HACKS!
Oh no, duh, OOOOOH my Goodness Gracious.
I ca-
WHAT?!
Whadyu mean hacked?!
Ooooh load of ass!
Aww, man I must not fully understand that
I think I had to go- let it go through the other loop first?
And then circle back to it it?
But man that's-
That's awfully inconVEINient
UGGGG
Again! AHH is it because it's day six I'm getting hacked a million ways?
Ah, man. This is not going well. This is going much worse than the last one.
Ok Got that done, got that done. I'll make that look like I was typing fast, instead of slow and stupid.
Bunker has nothing. I checked everything. The bunker doesn't have anything.
*Whispering* I don't see it. Oh I see it. There it is. *excitedly* okay I got three. Got three. Got three!
Ahh, I dunno what a Loogaroo is.
Oh, that is weird. What's a Loogaroo?
"We are the Sons and Daughters of The Loogaroo, our beloved mother."
"Long ago, our great mother made a pact with the merciful Lucifer. This pact was made in order for her to continue to serve us."
*female whispering in background*
Mark: *reverts to scared bunniplier* Okay
I don't like the whispering.
I don't like whispering in general, because I am a loud mother-humper.
"Join us and drink blood." You know, I'd rather not. I'd rather not drink blood.
Loogaroo ain't got nothing.
*Female whispering*
We're good.
We're good, Loogaroo.
We're fine!
Okay...
Weed post...nothing. Alright
Got it. Got it. Got it. Good. Good. Good. Okay.
I checked every button. Checked everything. We're good there, so I need to go back from the bottom to the top
The top to bottom again, skipping over the things that I know got nothing.
Oh! Give me them bathroom cams! Nope. * Russian knocking in the distance*
GeaHHHHH!
Okay, so I definitely think the small noises aren't anything
They're definitely not... though this is the one that gets me all the time. Okay.
So I think what has to happen, it has to hit every node that you can change, and then the end gets unlocked. That's what happens.
Okay. So that makes sense.
Voice: "And him, who was seated on it. From his presence, earth and sky fled away. A-"
Mark: *whispers* Okay! We got four! We got FOUR! WE GOT FOUR WE'RE DOING GREAT! (*claps*)
*one final grunt* Ah, I should've wrote down where I got 'em.
Okay, so, it's late night now. There's a lot of things in the beginning that don't seem to work
So I'm just checking through the ones that I have
For any late night ones.
That MAY work
Chosen awake didn't seem to do anything
This is the weirdnnnuh. I  don't like it.
Doesn't seem to do anything.
But I'm guessing
I'm gonna have some abductors
Crawling up my butt very soon.
God dammit...
Ughh these don't work
*Russian chair scrape*
*ominous chair scrape*
Man: *in Russian* Good evening.
HI.  At that point, I could've punched ya.
I coulda g-, delivered a wicked upper cut.
I did not knooooooow you were there. God Dammit.
God dammit.  AHH.
Am I supposed to check regularly I don't know...
God dammit. Ugh. Fucking...god dammit.
I'm gonna go again. I'm gonna go again! I don't wanna, I don't wanna, I don't wanna be back at the same point where I was before.
I wanna get four again .
And then I can end this episode and I can finish it up in another episode, because there is a way to continue, but I just wasn't able to get to it. (I QUIT! *throws computer off the balcony*)
Cause I'm an iiiidiot
My hair is a GOD DAMN MESS
Okay, this time what I'm gonna do is number one I'm not gonna get hacked
And that guy was probably waiting there for days just like:
He's gotta turn around eventually. My- my policy book says I must.  *mysterious narrator misses a snide remark*
DO this! I believe the noises are something now. I definitely think that the noises are most certainly something
Okay, so Cotton Road definitely nothing. I checked every single button
There's nothing on Cotton Road.
Okay.
Forgive me... Ooh.
Whoah!
*reading messages*
I was thinking that maybe if I clicked through this enough, there would be something here that looks like a code.
But it's all just really messed up confessions from a lot of really...unsettled people. But it seems like-
-it nothing here. So I'm going to put nothing for Forgive Me.
Ooh, there's a code! Okay- Voice: "Then I saw a great white throne. And him-"
Mark: I'm also gonna write down where I got it. Voice: "From his presen-"
Oh god that's the fire. God, I kept thinking that was something stip-stepping TIP-TOEING BEHIND ME.
*creepy, deep, music*
*grunts*
I dunno!
There's a lot of numbers in there. How am I supposed to-
If there's like a minus symbol in there, maybe...
I don't wanna. I don't wanna overlook this, to say that, this seems like it's gonna be a red herring. But I don't wanna overlook it and be like:
"OOOH NOOO!"
I wanna be sure-, if there's a single-
minus symbol
Okay I may have overlooked it but I do not see anything in that
big wall of text that looks like a minus symbol
So I'm gonna assume that it's nothing
Okay...I'm gonna assume it's nothing so
What was that...legion
no-nothing question mark
that's what I'm gonna put for legion
ah..geezums..aUGH
again...I'm finE!
totally fine, just a hack.
nothing wrong with a hack.
It's a kernel hack!
I can tip-type!
Flashbacks to my days with Mavis Beacon
Sniff those strings baby, sniff em.
Get sniff action.
*reading typing hack*
oooo..not quite right
Bam! Okay, easy peasy
Lemon squeeze me.
(beep) Oh my god...
Ohm my god.
Oh wow, you're kidding me, right?
Where is it?
wh-
You did the ding!
Where is it?
okay this is so absurd because
these buttons down here also count but it dInged
Where's my code?
I'm not a fool, I'm literally not seeing it!
Awh, you can't do that to meEE!
Oh, no, you can't do it!
Aw, man if you guys see it then I'm-
I'm very sorry, I don't think it's here!
I'm looking, and looking so closely!
(Russian chair scooting)
(Frantic light switch clicking)
Okay so, I marked the bunker down for a yes 'question mark' because
it did something
i-I just don't know WHAT!
woah-what was that? Woah, what was that?
OH!
oOh!
oh, oh my god, oh my god.
It was on my desktop
what is that?
oh, OH!
Huh?
WHAT THE HECK, I DIDNT KNOW THAT WAS GONNA BE THE THING!
THAT'S PROBABLY LIKE THE HARDEST ONE TO GET BECAUSE OF THE- oh, boy.
don't- don't screw this one up.
blamo, blamo, blamo, blamo, I got you!
Shut up.
Fuck you. Okay, got it.
So we got the hack blocked but the
I did know this was filling up, so
I can't get to day 30 or else it will be game over.
Who'd know that?
Me? I didn't know that
It's gotta be something because I clicked on it, it didn't click.
I clicked it, it just didn't do what it needed to do.
(beeping)
There we go.
YES! Okay, there we go.
Ugh, that's too stressful.
ub- whAT?
wha'd'ya doin'?
Don't do that to me!
Come on, I need to click on that thing
It's gotta be some---Oo, boy
Okay this is gonna be- oh no.
Oh no! oh... jeez
oh, boy. That was a close one. I did not
look at it very closely when it first went through. Ok.
But I got that one too.
Why another?
Ah, so many buttons on this page
Why are there so many buttons?
Theres SO many buttons! At least I'm going through the hard ones first, Maybe then it'll be easier for me.
Okay, that's going that way.
This needs to go down. Down!
Okay we got it, yeah, we're good, we're good.
What do you mean time? I don't know how to make-- oh.
There's nothing anyway.
(beep) There we go.
(whispering) Is it on my desktop?
Ohp!
There we go! Okay, got it.
(typing noises)
Okay, alright, okay, so
That three! That's all I need for now!
And supposedly, there's a way to continue the game after this
So, I'm doing good, I meticulously went through
everything
And I think I got the hard ones out of the way. SO if
I got the hard ones out of the way that's
good.
That means the rest of them are just ones that appear on the page
by themselves, which hopefully, I can get.
SO!
we'll see about this so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If I somehow screw up and I'm not able to
continue my game, we'll see about that. But I think I
actually, I think I have to get to the next day
for it to save, and
then go. So I'm gonna do that
But I'm gonna do that afterwards, and you guys don't have to worry about that unless I die for some reason, SO
Thank you everybody, so much for watching, and as always I'll see you in the next video. Buh bye!